le service public suivra mais il ne faut
pas inverser l'ordre des facteurs nos
territoires ruraux est d'abord et il
faut les embarquer dans la révolution
numérique
il est donc vital d'investir dans une
politique de réseau et de maillage
d'abord un accélérant la couverture de
tout le territoire en très haut débit
pour faciliter notamment le télétravail
la télémédecine d'où les usagers au
numérique les réseaux c'est aussi la
conservation des lignes ferroviaires
c'est aussi je le dis devant le sénat
peut-être réinvestir dans les routes
parce que à certains endroits
ce sont les seules voies pour
désenclaver les territoires
cela rejoint les débats que nous aurons
sur la décentralisation
doit-on conserver des routes nationales
que l'état a bien du mal à entretenir et
qu'il ne développe plus peut-on c'est
une question que je pose au sénat
puisqu'il a lui-même soulever renvoyé
pour autant cette responsabilité au
département
n'est-il pas temps de conforter les
régions dans leur rôle de responsable de
toutes les mobilités en envisageant des
routes structurantes d'intérêt régional
je soumets je soumets ses réflexions à
la sagacité du sénat
[Musique]